traduction avant cela revenons si vous
voulez si vous voulez bien sûr
l'évènement de cette journée un mur qui
s'effondre 28 ans ce mur a donc été
érigé pour couper une ville pour couper
un pays et aussi pour couper 2 europe
c'était le 13 août 1961 en pleine guerre
froide les autorités est allemandes
avaient édifié en une nuit
ce mur est devenu un symbole depuis un
symbole qui est tombée aujourd'hui
philippe couderc je vais 88 concert de
rock à berlin ouest de l'autre côté la
police charge les jeunes car ils
s'approchent trop près du mur pour
écouter michael jackson je veux 89
dernier anniversaire du mur de la honte
la contestation éclate de parts et
d'autres de checkpoint charlie
pour les manifestants ce mur long 211 km
doit tomber ce soir c'est chose faite
pour passer de l'autre côté il ne faudra
plus hautes et les barbelés comme ceux
soldats est-allemands ou rusé comme ce
chauffeur de taxi lui il a fait luire en
compagnie de deux mannequin déguisé en
militaire soviétique en revanche 77 ans
u auront été depuis 1961 a battu par les
vopos des centaines de familles divisées
des destins séparer des vies brisées
berlin un cancer au coeur de l'europe
avec son mur ces secteurs ces crises
successives l'europe qui s'installe dans
la guerre froide
le face-à-face permanent entre les
forces alliées les troupes soviétiques
à l'instar de john fitzgerald kennedy
l'ensemble du monde occidental devient
berlinois il faudra attendre 1970 pour
qu'intervienne les premiers signes de
détente le premier ministre est allemand
et monsieur stuff le chancelier fédéral
se nomme brandt en commun ils ont au
moins un prénom ville et ils vont
inaugurer une phase de cohabitation
voire de détente mais les candidats au
passage à l'ouest resteront très
nombreux il aura donc fallu 28 ans pour
que le mur de la honte soit frappée
d'inutilité
reste maintenant à régler le dossier
allemand un dossier délicat qui outre
les allemands concerne les alliés de 45
essentiellement français britanniques
américains et soviétiques